In interactive rendering systems, a color is defined by three values: red, green
and blue, abbreviated RGB. Each color value is often called a channel. These
values are usually in this order in most systems, RGB. That said, once in awhile
you'll run into data in the order BGR, blue, green, red. Which is RGB's evil
twin. Without properly swapping the channels, you'll see some odd-looking
images, such as this one on the right. The green stem looks fine, since the
green channel is in the same place, but what was once red is now blue. Okay, now
you've been warned. We usually define colors in one of two ways, as floating
point numbers or as integers. We'll start with floating points, since that's
generally the easier one to understand.